this week on wheel of science cannabis
nah actually it's it's based on yeah
chuck we're talking
solar system stuff on wheel of science
hey everybody i'm chuck nice and welcome
to wheel of science the interactive show
where we answer your questions about the
universe i don't answer your questions
about the universe
the one the only dr neil degrasse
tyson answers your questions about the
universe
what's up neil all good chuck all good
in the universe
it's earth that's messed up so neil
you're beaming in from san francisco huh
indeed yeah i had an uncle who actually
escaped from alcatraz no you don't and
no he didn't
of course i'm lying yes all right you
ready to jump into our first question
all right bring it on
[Music]
malik maz wants to know this why does
gravity produce elliptical orbits
why aren't they perfectly circular
what's up neil well all gravity really
does is change the path
that you would have otherwise taken
through space i'm trying to go in a
straight line
and something down here has got some
extra gravity for me i end up curving
towards that object but if i have high
enough speed
yeah my my trajectory will curve but it
won't get pulled into orbit it'll just
sort of send it in a different direction
and if i don't have enough speed it'll
curve me so much
i'll come in and crash it's only in
between those two extremes
that you end up having any kind of orbit
at all and you can have
all kinds of orbits depending on what
kind of speed you have and what your
distance is
comets typically have very elongated
oval orbits like that
and uh planets as we think of them tend
to have
much more circular orbits but they're
still ellipses
that there's a little known fact that
over enough time the interaction
between the object and the host it could
be a moon and a planet or a planet and a
star
over time the orbit becomes more and
more circular
in their interactions and depending on
how close it started and what the thing
is made of
it that can happen quickly and you can
end up with a perfectly circular orbit
eventually but otherwise gravity is just
something that changes your direction
that's all so maybe that's why pluto's
orbit is different than any other
planet did i say planet neal oh i'm
sorry it's
its orbit is so elongated it crosses the
orbit
of neptune there ain't no kind of
behavior for a planet i'm just saying
i'm joking neil i'm joking you wanna go
there are you ready for another question
yeah spin the wheel
matt hairfield wants to know why do
planets orbit in the direction that they
do or is it a 50 50 chance
an answer to that question was first
posed more than 250 years ago
in mid-1700s emanuel kant
uh the philosopher as well as
laplace a french mathematician physicist
proposed something called the nebular
hypothesis
because how else do you get all the
planets orbiting in the same direction
who ordered that and it turns out if you
have a gas cloud
that is the parent object that becomes
the star and its
orbiting planets and this gas cloud
rotates
as everything does in the universe and
it's out of that gas cloud that you make
your planets
and moons and other objects then
anything you make out of that gas cloud
is going to have
an orbit in the same direction around
the host star and the star will be
rotating
in that same direction so this was an
idea
250 years ago but later on more
thought invested in it computer models
bears this out
and so that's how you can have an entire
family of objects
everybody going in the same direction
and in fact that's so strong is that
concept and that idea that if you find
something orbiting the other way
you probably captured it later and it
did not
have anything to do with the formation
of the system itself
that's how you know who who's in the
who's got birthright
to the system and who came in later as
usual neil
that was a little mind blow that was
just a little one okay
that's all i did to you hey look we got
to take a break but when we come back
we're going to take a look at some
comments from the wheel of science group
and of course take more questions don't
go anywhere
wix.com is an amazing place to make your
own personal or business website
in fact i built wheelofscience.com
on wix it was super fast to embed videos
change fonts and add background photos
to create your own professional website
go to wix.com
slash go slash star talk make sure you
use that special star talk link
we also put it in the description send
us your sites in the comments
welcome back to wheel of science you
know what time it is no
no i don't what time is it time to spin
that wheel
remember all these questions come from
the wheel of science facebook group
aaron kennedy wants to know this could
you please explain the significance of
the heliosphere
and how it's made so the sun as we know
is a ball of gas
but it's not just all stays that way
some gas gets
like ejected and so there's a stream of
particles that come from the sun that we
call
the solar wind and you might have heard
of the solar wind because it makes
aurora
the particles stream and collide with
our atmosphere near the poles and it
renders it a glow very beautiful
well this solar wind moves completely
through
the solar system and it goes beyond the
planets beyond the comets
and there is a point where this solar
wind
can no longer be distinguished from the
medium that permeates
between the stars of the galaxy that is
the
actual edge of the sun's influence
the sun sort of particle influence on
its environment
and we call the size of that volume the
heliosphere
and the boundary of that volume the
heliopause
and on september 12 2013 voyager 1
the intrepid voyager 1 crossed the
heliopause
and only then could you say it has left
the solar system entirely
it's not just oh let's go beyond the
last planet and now you've left the
solar system no
no the sun reaches out far beyond
and there you have the heliosphere and
it's always there by the way and as we
move through the galaxy it can take on
different shapes
depending on what's going on around us
and depending on the strength of the
wind
at any given moment so it could be a
sphere but it's usually a teardrop
as the solar system moves as we orbit
the center of the galaxy the milky way
galaxy there you have it chuck all right
neil that's the heliosphere but can you
answer this
what is the crappiest fear no you can't
cause i just made it up
it's my life i got nothing for you on
that all right now
on a serious note you know we did an
episode about asteroids and i actually
saw this comment in the facebook group
comments
uh ray parker said this i don't care
or want to hear about asteroids if we
get hit so be it
nothing we could do about it there are
other things that are a lot
more important than rocks
meal this is why you want scientists and
engineers in your midst
because when something that might render
you extinct
arises is on its way towards earth they
will
turn they will look up and say how can
we prevent that
and they'll use methods and tools and
ingenious
ideas and that can be the difference
between you being alive saying you don't
care
and you being extinct where your
thoughts then wouldn't matter to anyone
amen nobody can argue with that i'm
picking the reality where my president
is morgan freeman and now i have a
question for all of you watching
elon musk announced the first commercial
flight around the moon
would you want to be on that trip
answer the poll right now i don't want
to
thanks again to wix.com for bringing
wheel of science to youtube
you can create a website with wix in
just minutes
they have templates on literally
everything
take a look at the template i used for
wheelofsides.com
in less than an hour i customized it so
it would look and
feel like our show look at this
this is amazing customization was super
simple
they gave me a million fond choices and
every single element was customizable
in just a few clicks look at that that's
a website
that's a wheel of science website check
out our site
and when you're done make your own go to
wix.com go slash star talk to make your
professional website
you can upgrade it and add your own
domain and get some really great
extra features with their premium plans
click on that link in the description
and get started on your website right
away
also share this show even if the person
isn't from
earth they need to see it too as always
thanks to neil degrasse tyson thanks
neil you know i love you chuck
i love you too man that was weird hey
i'm chuck knight saying
until next time this is
[Music]
you